oh hello there
I think we're alive I'm back holy [ __ ]
how's it going where you been where have
I been
holy moly we have a lot to catch up on
people
all right this actually feels quite
surreal to me I normally do this almost
every day or I do interviews or talk to
people or go on other people's shows or
I'm reading the news part of this whole
thing fighting with people on Twitter
the whole shebang I did not do any of it
for a month and a real month nothing
nothing I did not know anything about
the news I did not look at my phone I
did not tweet any of that stuff we had
one of my guys doing my were one of my
gals actually doing doing Twitter stuff
for us and taking care of the Facebook
post just to get all the the show stuff
out there but I personally did not do
anything i I left the grid on August 4th
so that was one month and one day ago I
was in New York City I had just done a
little something my original intention
was I did an event on August 8th with
Richard Dawkins which I'm going to talk
a little bit about and hopefully some of
you guys saw that video my intention was
to go off the grid after that but the
morning of the fourth I had done
something on Sirius XM in the morning
with my buddy David Webb and I was
walking in the city and I realized I had
about four days still in the city before
the Dawkins event you know I have some
family in the city and friends and all
that and I was walking in the city and
it was a beautiful day and just that
knee-jerk need and response and an
activity of constantly going to your
phone looking at it all of this nonsense
and I was like you know what if I
publicly just announce I'm doing it
right this second then I know that I'll
be able to hold myself to it so I sent
off a little string a tweet saying that
I was disappearing and and going off the
grid and I and I did it so as of August
4th no nothing really
so I'll skip ahead for just a second
here I have my original intention today
that I was gonna come here sit down just
like we're doing this right now
I was gonna come back and do this and
have no idea of what's been going on and
do that straight with you just actually
do like a Q&A thing where you guys could
tell me what's been going on or I would
have had a mirror and David just reading
me some news things to catch up at one
point I thought maybe I'd have I was
gonna ask my buddy Colin Moriarty to
come in and catch me up because I think
he's pretty astute on the news and a
good guy but then two days ago on
today's Tuesday so Sunday night I was
invited to a dinner with some former
guests of the show it was kind of a big
thing and Eric Weinstein who as you guys
know is a multiple Reuben report guest
multiple time appearances and and I've
become a good buddy of mine and a and a
friend and I was almost gonna say mentor
but uh but he's one of the people that I
go to when I'm confused about things or
I need some counsel on something anyway
I met him about an hour before the
dinner and and he said look at this
dinner people are gonna be talking about
everything that's going on there why
don't I just get you up to speed so we
spent about an hour just getting me up
to speed on the major thing so I had not
heard about what happened in
Charlottesville I had not heard about
the hurricane I had not heard about some
of this Google stuff I just scribbled a
few things down here
I hadn't heard about this this daca
thing which I guess is unfolding right
now I hadn't heard about anything the
only one thing that I did hear about in
the month was that for a couple days
that towards the beginning of the month
I was in Mexico just trying to I was
working on the book but really just for
at least a few days of it just trying to
like lay on a beach and just clear my
mind I mean just clear the mental
clutter that all of us have right we all
have this endless onslaught of news all
the social media stuff obviously someone
like me I'm in it in an extremely
intimate way so the only thing that I
heard was that while I was in Mexico I
was doing cardio everyday I tried to I
think I can you tell I lost the weight
Oh a sort of a beard how about that and
anyway so I was doing cardio every day
and the TV that was in front of me every
day was ESPN espanol so I did see
something about hashtag
Barcelona from a lot of athletes oh I
did ascertain that there was a terror
attack in Barcelona I know nothing of it
beyond that but what was interesting is
that when I was in Mexico and I was at
one of these like all-inclusive resorts
where you just plop down and you know
you pay for everything up front so you
there everything's free while you're
there so you don't leave the resort
basically and people were coming and
going and you meet people and I was
really trying not to be I can breathe be
decently social but I was trying not to
actually because I really just want I
didn't want to talk news with people
first off and everyone was always talk
news and a couple times people would
come up to us we'd be in the pool they'd
want to start talking news I'd say I'm
completely off the grid what I would say
that I'm off the grid and I literally my
phone was literally locked in a safe
that I did not have a code to I would
tell people this and I'd say well I'm
off I started a week to go ten days ago
I'm off till you know for another couple
weeks people it like blew people's mind
that everybody was like how can you
possibly you're doing it I can't believe
you're doing it I wish I could do it and
what about work emails and blah blah
blah and all these people that are on
vacation that was my one major take away
just on the total just digital front and
using these devices and all that stuff
and the iPhone is that the amount of
people the inability to shut down even
when you're on vacation so we're at we
were in Cabo which is kind of close to
LA it's like a two-hour flight and and
it's just beach resorts that's it so I'm
basically just sitting at a pool that's
just facing the beach and that's it and
I really was just focusing on clouds in
the waves and just I could feel my mind
just decluttering just all that [ __ ]
that's up there I could feel it kind of
just you know opening up some new doors
closing some other doors it was it was
nice but then I look around the pool and
all of these people who are staring at
Beauty I mean just an ocean and some
clouds and some gorgeous waves and
they're all people taking selfies
everyone's taking pictures of their
frozen drinks people are type battling
you know banging on the iPad and all
that stuff and just the inability to
escape some of the digital madness and I
say this with all due irony is someone
that creates content on the in the
digital space and that you guys are
watching this digitally right now and
I'm doing it
right now and all that stuff but I did
give me some perspective and you know
that I've talked about this stuff and
I've had Tristan Harrison who's a former
Google guy who is talking about the way
is that they kind of trick you into
always needing more and more of that but
I gotta tell you getting away from it
you know well I'll talk about the news
part separately but getting away from
just looking at the phone constantly
like my hand going to my pocket if I was
just standing on a corner this happened
a couple times because I wasn't doing
anything with my phone and didn't have
it with me if I was meeting somebody I
didn't have a phone I'd have to just
stand you know in the old days you were
meeting someone oh I'll meet you on the
corner of 43rd and Lex well you'd have
to at noon well you'd have to wait there
and hope that they'd show up and you
couldn't just stare at a phone all the
time you couldn't track them or track
yourself or drop a pin or any of that
stuff and just doing simple things like
that was it felt good it felt good it
was like a throwback I felt like a
throwback to some other some other time
also just getting away from the news in
general you know it's funny even though
I'm just catching up on all this stuff
and I don't want to go too deep into
what I missed because obviously I'm
gonna have some catching up to do by the
way we're taping later this afternoon
we're taping an interview with Phil
DeFranco who as you guys know I consider
to be one of the guys who really is
doing something really good and honest
and decent in the news space so we're
taping that today it'll be up tomorrow
so maybe we'll talk more about the
specifics of what I missed maybe he can
enlighten me on some stuff and all that
but I gotta tell you i whatever happened
even if there's ten other things that I
didn't get to hear or whatever I don't
feel less informed if anything I
actually as I sit here on September 5th
right now after being off the grid for
since the 4th of August I feel more
informed actually I feel more
clear-minded on everything because the
world continues the world continues so
when I saw this this hashtag Barcelona
thing that I'm in the pool and a bunch
of people when I wouldn't talking about
the news would come up or somebody was
like you know did you see what's going
on I was like I I'm off that I'm off the
grid and they said well one big thing
happened one big big thing happened and
I assumed they were talking about
Barcelona apparently it sounds to me now
in retrospect that people are actually
talking about what happened in
Charlottesville and again we'll get to
all that over the next couple weeks and
I'll have some people on talking about
all
stuff and I got a fee I got to read
enough to have a comprehensive thought
that I can give you on all that but
anyway there's so there's a bunch of
stuff that I want to do in this live
stream right now and by the way we're
going casual today I don't know if you
note my my very nice classical liberal
t-shirt so contrary to the to the people
online who say that Dave Reubens an all
right member he is not classical liberal
which by the way is for we're selling
these
it's a Reuben report.com slash store am
I correct
someone will confirm that for me and I'm
really going casual today just wearing
socks in the studio that is r2 that is
c-3po right there
and that is that is can you see r2
there's there's our doodie - over there
all right so there's a whole bunch of
stuff that I want to catch up on with
you guys so first off so yeah I went off
the grid had a couple days in New York
City catching up with family and stuff
like that then I did this event with
Richard Dawkins which we posted the
video right here it was great I mean
this is a guy that I've wanted to meet
for so long just to sit down with even
if it wasn't gonna be on camera just you
know one of the great minds I think that
we have in the world today and I've
interviewed so many of his
contemporaries and the people you know
sort of around him from Sam Harris to
Lawrence Krauss to Michael Shermer and
Peter Bogosian and and all of these
people we've all sort of been around in
the same world that Kim keeps coalescing
in a way and so he did it at the 92nd
Street Y I actually thought and I think
I said this before I thought we were
doing it in the massive theater that
they have there but I actually closed
that for the summer for renovations and
because this thing happened so quickly
we did it in a smaller room it was very
intimate it was great it was immediately
sold out and it was just great to talk
to the guy and connect with him and I
felt that he genuinely I don't know that
he knew much about me before him but I
felt that there was like a true sort of
mutual respect thereafter and hopefully
we'll be able to do some stuff in the
future but it was sort of even though I
had gone off the grid a couple days
before it kind of felt like like when I
was done with that I really knew I could
just like kind of flip the switch and
shut my mind down and it just it just
felt great
begin to tell you how nice it was to
have that be the thing that that let me
go so now I want to say what I think is
the most important thing that I'm
probably gonna say in this hour and by
the way we're gonna take questions on
patreon I know people are submitting
questions right now we're also gonna do
a super chat thing so you guys can ask
me some questions but but the most
important thing that happened to me over
the the last month is that I constantly
found in the moments of silence or quiet
if I was just laying on the beach and I
want to talk to you about the book also
but wherever I was if I was at dinner or
even just having a cup of coffee or
around in this last week and a half that
I've been back home and I've been
working on the book I've been doing more
gardening some other stuff but I
constantly found a real sense of
gratitude that you guys that especially
those of you the you know the 4,000 or
so of you that support me on patreon and
now we're doing monthly things on PayPal
as well the people that support wherever
wherever you do it wherever you do it or
have done it or whatever that you guys
gave me the ability to do what I just
did I mean I truly had one of the I
think one of the best months of my life
because it would it gave me perspective
it gave me a sense to breathe and calm
down I feel incredibly invigorated right
now to be back doing what I'm doing I
think I want to continue of course the
conversations we're having but there are
new ways that I think I want to start
doing some things I want to strengthen
everything we've been doing and maybe
push the show in some other directions
to challenge my own beliefs and all that
stuff but I felt a constant this was a
constant throughout the month
just an incredible gratitude to those of
you that support me because you allowed
me to do this you allowed me to work on
the book you allowed me to shut down the
average person does not get to do that
and you guys enabled me to do that and I
and I'm forever grateful for that and I
think that the payback that I can now
give you is by doing better work than
ever before and that's what I intend on
doing so all right so there's a few
other things that that I want to talk
about here
let's talk a little bit about YouTube
itself for a second because that is the
the main platform that we're doing this
thing on so I did do one work thing I
had to take one work haul in the month
and about a week ago I think it was week
or so maybe ten days ago I took one call
it was a call with YouTube because as
some of you know oh by the way we we
passed 500 thousand subscribers when I
was gone so that was great
but as you know I've been saying that we
I get messages every day from people who
tell me their unsubscribed
from the channel every day they say Dave
I know I'm subscribed but now I see that
I'm unsubscribed your videos don't show
it by feed I click the little bell blah
blah blah we know that video you guys
all know this partnering that the videos
are being demonetised that absurd rates
we had something like we got informed
that something like 600 of our videos
got demonetised
we also you'll find this particularly
crazy so we're not when I left so you
guys know I left end of July is when I
wrapped up and we had taped a whole
bunch of shows so the shows that you got
when I was gone we did be on Dawkins we
had GAD sad and we had your own Brook
and we had Guy Benson and Pia Milani and
all of these episodes were in the can
ready to go and what we do is when Amira
edits them she uploads them to YouTube
and usually until we title them meaning
you know GAD sad on religion or whatever
it is part one that it usually just has
some numbers it's just like numbers and
letters it's just nonsense and then our
guys get in there and tag a title and
all that suddenly for the first time
ever wrote for the past month videos of
ours that had no tags meaning it didn't
say anything about religion it said no
words there was nothing that might be
scary to advertisers on their videos
that had no titles and no tags meaning
all it was was the raw footage uploaded
now to the back of YouTube those were
being D monetized this has never
happened before and this is actually
crazy I mean think about it there it's
basically they're they're proving us
guilty rather than allowing us to be
innocent you know we're guilty before
innocent which is which is insane so
anyway so I took a call with YouTube
because we've been going back and forth
with YouTube David has has an endless
email chain there they're impossible to
get through every response that they
give you when I tweet
YouTube on Twitter and all that they
just it's endless we're gonna escalate
this we'll move this up the chain we're
looking into this
we're teams working on that like there's
literally never and I know he's
literally a lot but there is never an
answer they never give you an answer no
one the buck stops with no one oh we'll
look into that
so anyway so we have this call with them
for about an hour I I was I've been in a
good place in the last month so I was
being pretty Pleasant and I want the
platform as I said to jack conte from
patreon you know I want the platform to
succeed this is this is the platform at
on this the discovery here is unmatched
unrivaled anyway the conversation was
actually quite ridiculous we just got no
answers on anything they couldn't tell
us if people were being unsubscribed or
not they couldn't tell us why the D
monetization is happening before we even
tag and title the videos they assured us
that we're not being targeted but I also
think it's possible that that whoever
you're talking to there we had two
YouTube people there but they don't even
know what's actually going on really
with the algorithm where it's at the
highest the highest levels of what's
actually happening so anyway I mention
all this because you know we're putting
this thing on YouTube next week we have
Douglas Mari who's coming in from the UK
and we're putting them up and all that
kind of stuff and we're we're investing
more and more into the show I mentioned
that right before we went off the off
the grid we installed some new lights
around here because when we do the panel
shows like I did with Shermer and Prager
we needed a third chair to be to be lit
that was about 5,000 bucks
you know we're investing in travel and
all kinds of other things and I just at
this point right now and then I'll get
off this topic and we can talk about
some other stuff but at this point the
our YouTube revaz cut about 75% it's
actually insanely ridiculous there d
monetizing us on things that have
nothing to are two of our videos with
Pia Milani who is a left-wing economist
we didn't talk about anything
controversial we didn't talk I don't
think we really talked about anything
other than that the economy that these
things are being demonized at a crazy
level and it's making our business of
being here a problem so I want the
discovery here but again this is exactly
why
you guys who if you support us on
patreon or PayPal or whatever it is you
know we put ads now on our on our
podcast and we'll figure out all the
other different ways but I think it's
important for me to be transparently
with you about this and also as I got
back on the grid today I did see a lot
of emails from people and people that
were messaging me about just everyone's
having a problem with YouTube right now
and I actually wonder you know Google is
a public company I wonder if the board
fully understands what is happening on
the D modernization side because they
have a fiduciary responsibility to do
what's most profitable for the
shareholders and I suspect a lot of this
is politically motivated I look I don't
know but anyway I want to be transparent
about how we're trying to do business
here and you know patreon obviously took
a hit because of the lauren southern
thing and then sam Harris announced he
was leaving ultimately he decided to
stay but I think patreon lost a whole
bunch of people so we did take a dip
there too so any we're trying to figure
out all this stuff but if you if you
missed me and you think what we're doing
is good and for the month that I took
off that you you still got brand new
content every week and you wanna you
want to continue that and help us grow
and all that stuff it's Rubin report.com
slash donate so I'm just throwing that
out there and then we'll we'll jump into
some other things so a couple things
before I get to to the Q&A here and I
see that there's a zillion things going
on your o so the book okay so I mean
that was the main reason I took off so
had the first few days in New York and
that I was just kind of seeing family
and stuff then I had the Dawkins thing
and then the next day I went to Mexico
and I wanted like two or three days just
to do nothing and I just needed it you
ever just had I mean I did like a good
like 72 hour just on the beach
nothing just in the pool playing out
going to the gym nothing really worked
on I'm eating right and I didn't drink
much over the last month and I've been
working out like crazy what do you guys
think of the of the beard by the way I'm
we're deciding it's gonna be a team
decision on where this thing goes I'm
kind of diggin it what do you what do
you guys feeling anyway so what after
two or three days basically I realized
that my brain actually needed a little
more time to
compress so what I was doing was I had a
notebook out there and I've been and I
was writing a whole bunch of stuff and
then over the last couple weeks now that
I've been home I've been working on it
again I can tell now I now know what my
my good buddy Peter Burgos ian has said
that writing a book is gonna be the
hardest thing your life I now know that
is true and there were like 18 different
pivots that I was doing where you know a
lot of what I was trying to write was
the why I left all that thing but then I
was trying to blend it into sort of the
online world and just sort of political
stuff that's happening now and I wanted
to tell a little bit more of my own
personal story and all of these things
so it's coming together it's coming
together I think it's gonna take a
little more time than then I thought but
I'm gonna show what I have to my editor
and then I think she'll probably get it
in some sort of sensible way that we can
kind of move forward on that
but even that even my ability to just
sit it was also nice I literally didn't
look at the screen so except when I was
at the gym and the TV was right in front
of me and as I said it was ESPN espanol
it was nice not to look at screens ever
even just coming back today like looking
at a bright screens it's like they're
very bright these screens so so anyway
so that's where we're at with the book
and I'm gonna keep pushing through and
I'll keep you guys posted as we're doing
it but again I could not have afforded
to do this if it wasn't for those of you
that that you know that help us do this
so I'm just I'm incredibly new
appreciative to all this stuff one of
the other things I just want to say
about about Twitter specifically because
I just this morning I'm back on and I
haven't even really looked in my
mentions but I just tweeted out that I'm
doing this right now and I fell on or
whatever else it became so obvious to me
as I quickly glanced through the my feed
that so much of what whatever is
happening in the world so much of this
is being dictated by like just this
endless noise and craving for more
retweets and likes and all the stuff now
I know I'm not saying anything that's
like magically you know magically
revelry revelatory right there but I
think so many of the things and maybe
I've been a victim of this myself at
some level is that you know everyone
wants retweets and likes and all this
stuff and we're fighting with people
that we don't know we're outraged about
people that we've never heard of until
they suddenly someone you never heard of
said something about something you don't
care about now you you can you convert
you'll your signal virtue signal your
way into getting them and just the
amount of anonymous accounts that are
just what I realized was there's just so
many people out there right now and
they're mostly anonymous accounts but
not all and by the way there's some
reasons that anonymity online is valid
in certain cases but these people that
just want to watch the world burn these
people that just want to upset everybody
and make everybody think that all hell
is breaking loose and everyone hates
everybody and everyone's racist and all
of this stuff and by the way these a lot
of people that are just endlessly
pushing out truly evil hateful racist
memes and all that stuff like there's a
certain amount of people that just want
to [ __ ] with everybody and watch the
whole thing burn and I don't want to
strengthen those people in any way and
I'm not gonna strengthen them in any way
I don't think that's really what I've
done but I want to be even more aware of
that because it just so hits me that
we're watching right now and again this
I'm saying this is someone that's been
out of the loop for the last month but
from what I've seen in a little bit
couple hours of being back that the
extremes that if you think that there
now is this sort of you know that this
all right or white supremacist or
whatever you think that thing is well
it's been for the last two years what
what have we been talking about on this
show pretty consistently it consistently
it's been the left has to it start
becoming liberal again looking at
individuals now looking at groups that
is actually prejudice if you look at
someone by their skin color or sexuality
and then you think you can understand
them because of that or you think they
should think certain things that's
prejudging that's prejudice and I think
that's why I've tried so hard for the
last two years to try to get the left to
not do that because ultimately of course
it was going to lead to sort of either a
white identitarian movement using the
same tactics of collectivism that the
left is using or whatever is happening
but again I don't want to go too far
into that right now because I have to
see exactly what's happening here but
but my overriding point being that I
just I want to keep having conversations
with people who are truly saying
something even if they're saying things
that I disagree with but that that are
truly trying to find some answers and
change
the world in the right way again I may
not agree with the specifics of what
they want or even or what they're doing
or their outcome but that are truly
trying to do saying versus just we all
get caught in this noise of just these
crazy people just screaming [ __ ] all day
long
and by the way when I was off and I saw
some friends and family and things like
that you know telling people at a dinner
table you know we're not gonna do
politics tonight because I'm off the
grid I don't want to hear any of that
you know most people at first they kind
of like about Trump this and you know
but I want this happening but putting
that aside people also there's a lot of
other things you can talk about you
could talk about art and philosophy and
AI and sports and a gajillion other
things and I think that the the constant
attack an onslaught that the media is
putting into us that every little
political decision all hell is gonna
break loose I mean you know even if you
think so I've been off for about a month
remember those Comey hearings all about
Russia and everyone said well this is
the smoking gun this is the smoker than
Trump juniors meeting about this is a
smoking gun it's like well what happened
any of that but we all spending all this
time focusing on all this political
nonsense
and again it's why I always say the best
government is one small enough that they
can't affect you in every way and and
I'm gonna keep pushing that idea - all
right so there's a lot there's a lot of
people here all right so it looks like a
lot of people are digging the beard so
I'm happy to hear that oh you know I
didn't somebody saying hey Dave I glad
you enjoyed your vacation any thoughts
on the North Korea situation plans on
getting to Franco on the show and what
about lesser-known razörfist so I'm not
sure who razörfist is defranco's on
today will it'll be up tomorrow and as
for the North Korea thing so Erik caught
me up for about ten minutes I obviously
need to read more before I comment about
it as a general rule I'm not for pre
emmett pre preeminent strikes I'm not
for attacking first you can see I've
been out of it for a little bit and and
I thought we'd have to see what's really
going on there on super trad somebody
said thanks for having Douglas Mari my
pleasure you know I had him on once on
skype about two years ago I'm very
excited to to sit down with him
someone on super chat said lucky you of
us who needs ad revenue anyway yeah you
know what the funny thing is on the on
the super chat you know YouTube takes a
percentage of that number whatever you
put in to do that I don't know what the
percentage is offhand but the the simple
thing is that the ad revenue YouTube has
just become I'd be an idiot if I was
running a business that I was relying on
that ad revenue it's down and measurably
and the fact that they're I mean this
concept really think about this they are
D monetizing some of our videos before
we've attached any metadata now that
can't be happening on every channel I
would venture to say and I asked the guy
outright and he said no but I don't know
that he knows or would tell me I said
are you telling me that on left-leaning
or whatever the SJW or whatever you want
to call that you're telling me on those
political channels that their videos are
being demonetised before they have any
metadata and he said no but how can I
believe that and why would you be doing
that anyway how does that make sense if
you look I said to the guy look I give
you a television quality show if this
show this show could be on television
tomorrow we get offers to do bigger
things bigger it's all relative but we
get offers to do all kinds of other
things with this show I love what we're
doing now when I talk to you about
gratitude before I realized that I in a
certain way there's always things that I
want to change there's always things
that I want to grow there's always
things that I want to expand on all that
but in a certain way I kind of have
exactly the operation that I want right
now we control this thing we've got a
great little business running we're
figuring out all those other ways to do
it I don't know if one of the networks
came to me and offered me you know seven
figures honestly I don't know that I
would do it I really don't I don't at
this point why would I want to even but
that being said I have to be smart about
how we can continue to make a functional
business and unfortunately YouTube's
just making it impossible for us
somebody's hasn't met a panel discussion
with your own Brooke and Jordan Peterson
they have some interesting disagreements
they absolutely do you know it's so
interesting because so if you saw my
interview with your own which we put up
two weeks ago I really liked him I think
he makes great arguments for rational
self-interest and and Jordan Peterson
does now they have differences on where
what religion
that I'd love to sit down both to them
I'm actually doing some events with the
iron Rand Institute over the next couple
months I'm gonna be at Harvard on David
correct me if I'm wrong on January 19th
with Brett Weinstein and Steve Simpson
and then I'm gonna be I think Clemson
with with Jordan Peterson a little bit
after that but anyway yes I'd be happy
to get your own and Jordan to sit down I
think that would be I think that would
really be great okay here we go from
patreon I guess my question as a guy
who's jealous of any unplugging success
how long did it take before you
regretted plugging back in what was the
most shocking bit of news you cashed up
on that's good you know this morning
okay so Eric yeah I'm right on the it's
xx xx Harvard with Brett Weinstein so
you can look into that so as I said two
days ago Eric gave me just the breakdown
but I wasn't watching TV or even looking
at my phone or any of that stuff he gave
me the breakdown of what was going on
and I felt it was as I said I wanted to
do it straight up with you I wanted to
just sit here today and do this with you
guys but because of the dinner that I
was going to it seemed like the right
way to do it and as I said Eric's the
right guy to fill me in on this stuff
so to your question I gotta say when I
woke up this morning so last night so
used to be before this little break you
know I'd have my phone on my nightstand
and sometimes I'd be looking at it
before I went to bed and then sometimes
I'm looking at it right when I wake up
and that's not really a normal way to
start the day I can scroll Twitter and
see how many people told me to go [ __ ]
myself before I've had coffee like
that's not that's not normal by the way
90 percent of the interaction I get
everywhere is positive it's this you
know there's always gonna be the little
loud haters and trolls and all that okay
fine but anyway last night right before
bed I walked into the bedroom and I had
my phone and I was about to put it on
the nightstand I was like you know what
no I'm not gonna do this so no more
phone in the bedroom so I am actually
setting up some new rules for myself in
general no more phone in the bedroom I
will not look at my phone or even my
iPad unless it's for reading you know
reading a book an e-book I'm not gonna
be doing that in the bedroom I don't
want my day your day should not start
with the immediacy even even if you're
not on social media your day doesn't
need to start with the immediacy of what
happened today and who can I be outraged
about and how did this
that doesn't mean you don't have to be
informed I tell you this as someone I
loved logic and reason and education and
all of these things you gotta be
informed but you also gotta live a
decent life so I learned a little
something on that so I would say the
most jarring part of coming back truly
is he's looking at the screens like just
looking at screens there's something
different I've been looking at people
for the last month I've been sitting
down across the table with people I do
do this normally too but when you really
take a month off screens you think a
little bit about how weird it is that
we're all walking around with our heads
down look into this crack yo you'll love
this so I'm about to get off the grid
I'm in New York City so though this is
so this is what actually pushed me
finally when I told you I got off a few
days earlier that I wanted to so I walk
out of Sirius XM and I was that's on
about 50th and sixth or so and I walk
over to the Time Warner Center that's
the building that CNN is in and I go
downstairs to Whole Foods I was gonna
get a iced tea and I'm on my phone I get
the iced tea I'm on my phone and I'm
looking at something and I started
walking up the down escalator I kid you
not I kid you not
and these three girls I don't know
probably a little younger than me all
kind of laughing at me and I you know
and then I was like man I just looked
the most like yeah I need a break
and then and then they laughed it was a
funny little exchange but I almost
walked up and down escalator in New York
City you know so that's what that's when
I was finally like alright and then I
was while I walked up to the Upper West
and I sent that little chain out and
whatever so I would say the most jarring
part it's not the news yet so I don't
want to address the specific news stuff
because I still got to take that in more
you know obviously what happened to
Charlottesville I need to track and
figure out what's going on there and how
real is this this rise of whatever this
is on the right right now I want to find
out more about the hurricane which is
obviously sounds horrific okay let's see
can you try to interview Norwegian
integration minister Sylvie lista
you've gotten Larry King on the show so
this shouldn't be hard I'm trying to
connect with Larry this week actually I
don't know who who that person is but I
will I will look into it one of the
things that I really want to do you know
I consider this as of today
and the show that we're gonna do with
Phil that'll be up tomorrow I consider
this season 3 of the Rubin report in my
mind I want to start doing things a
little more in seasons I think part of
the problem people are having a bun
plugging and disconnecting from the news
is that we don't have seasons anymore
because everything's digital so all
these people are always putting out
content all the time there are great
creators that are putting out stuff
seven days a week you know to me my
feeling is if we put out one or two
shows and plus a live stream if you give
me an it believe me if you give me an
hour of your week if you spend an hour
of your week to listen to an important
conversation or listen to me talk or do
a Q&A or whatever it is there's so much
stuff out there that I think is a lot of
time so I think that a lot of these
people they're putting out more stuff
and there's actually diminishing returns
on it you know what I mean you got to
live your life - so I think we're gonna
my goal is to we'll do one or two a week
plus a live stream something like that
but I don't think we need to expand
specifically beyond that I want to start
taking the show on the road more
actually I think by the way that we're
going to be live-streaming that event at
Harvard and some of the other things
that we're doing let's see from patreon
under what conditions when you consent
to war with North Korea and would you
consent to American soldiers on the
ground man getting right back into it
huh well look I need to figure out more
what's happened I guess this was a test
of a hydrogen bomb and there was
something about an ICBM that was shot up
and now they can figure out how far I
can actually go there's almost I don't
want to get too ahead of myself on this
one but I would say there's almost no
situation at this point anywhere on
earth that I would be for American
troops on the ground in some sort of
real capacity some sort of peacekeeping
thing or defending people something like
that but occupying a country or some of
that stuff no but I would need to I need
to figure out what happened there more
why do you think that so many left
wingers are desperate to prove that
you're a right winger
well this is that that's kind of funny
cuz so I did over the course of the last
month it happened twice in Mexico and a
few times just wandering around the area
that I live in here
you know people come up to me and talk
about stuff and a few people that did
know I was go off the grid so try not to
burden me with stuff but people asked me
about that
all the time like how do you what do you
think about your being called alright or
a far-right wing or above a as some of
that's been a way for this a little bit
it's beyond meaningless and it's why all
the labels and all of this stuff as I've
tried to talk about for the last year
especially it's why these things are
becoming increasingly meaningless and I
see it you know apparently so the the
guy at Google who wrote the memo James
d'amour who I think we're gonna have on
the show I just got in contact with him
this morning actually you know
that putting all of these these ideas
together whatever we're talking about
here where if you think that someone who
could be gay married and who is
pro-choice and is for funding an
education system and is you know for
assisted suicide and for reforming the
prison system and for legalizing
marijuana and all these things if you if
that person to you is far-right or alt
right then that's a pretty freakin big
tent that those right-wingers have those
evil right-wingers I think part of the
problem and again this is why I talk
about the left so much is I want the
left to return to Reason and all of that
and and to logic and because they've
abandoned that all they've got are these
labels so when James do more I just
googled some stuff this morning as I was
catching up on all this I guess James
d'amour said in in a reddit that he's a
fan of what I do and then I saw some
articles I think one was in Think
Progress
about him being fans of right-wing
things and then they quoted me on a
direct message that I did that didn't
sound right wing at all but this is all
these people have and it needs to be it
needs to be dismissed and treated as
drivel and one of the things that I'm
also gonna try to do now is give less
credence to this nonsense so I over the
last couple of months I've had a lot of
really [ __ ] terrible libelous
articles written about me from all kinds
of places and in some cases I went on
full attack and in some places I just
ignored it because I didn't want to add
fuel to the fire but I'm now realizing
almost everything that you read out of
mainstream media is pretty much garbage
it's all slanted nonsense and it makes
it harder for you to figure out what's
right but I'm gonna
spend less time defending myself and I'm
just gonna go on what all I can do is
tell you what I think and those thoughts
could be right or wrong or in the middle
but I can't worry about what just what
people are gonna say about me I just
genuinely can let's see I think we have
Michelle malleus coming on soon to talk
about North Korea by the way I'm sorry
Michael malice Michelle malice Michael
Mouse man I have been out of it for a
while okay let's see
let me give a oh I see that my buddy
Faisal and Patrick Winston are in the
facebook chat how you doing guys where
can i buy the t-shirt so we've got a
whole bunch of new merch because as I
said we are trying to be a business and
because we cannot trust the YouTube Rev
anymore we got some great new shirts
that my sister is an artist that she
designed including this one and it's
Ruben report.com slash store we're doing
a whole bunch of stuff through teespring
we've got a new center shirt I was gonna
wear that one today maybe I'll do
another stream later in the week and
wear that one we got a couple other cool
classical liberal ones and some other
Rubin reports often there's mugs and
sweatshirts and hoodies and t-shirts and
long sleeves and girls shirts and blah
blah blah all that stuff Dave this SJW
nonsense writes itself why are no
comedians capitalizing on it this is one
of the things I was talking about a lot
before I went off comedians
unfortunately many many I don't include
include Joe Rogan a couple others in
this have become hysterical crying
babies so like when Milo's book was
coming out and I saw plenty of famous
comedians that I know demanding that
Simon & Schuster not released the book
it's like when since when are comedians
for censorship since when are comedians
for silencing opposition comedians are
supposed to fight [ __ ] with comedy
and these people unfortunately have all
become sort of leftist groupthink robots
so many of the comics these days so when
I go to schools now and I'm talking to
these kids and I sort of incorporate a
little stand-up into it and I play with
the crowd a little bit it's like there
are things that are cool right now i
think i think that logic and reason and
liberty i think these things are cool
and there's there's a lot of funny to be
made about the sjw's and all the
nonsense and I'm trying to I'm trying to
run with that a little bit because it's
it depresses me
as somebody that loves comedy okay
welcome back to if we've missed you
please never stop making your fantastic
content it's needed more than ever love
the new look please follow your Twitter
fanpage at Dave Reubens beard oh my god
the beard has a Twitter fanpage welcome
back Dave I hear Crowder's hiring a new
producer someone who's not gay is not
gay Jarrod out of there what happened
sometimes I feel people are so focused
on the federal level of government could
you please interview people making a
difference in state and county level
government that's a great idea it's one
of the reasons that as I've said that I
believe in this in classical liberalism
because that gets the power back to the
local governments we shouldn't be giving
all of this power to the federal
government if the federal government can
control everything well then if you
don't like it you can't just move to
another state you got to leave the
country I would always rather the the
little part of Los Angeles that I live
in right now that the exit that I live
off of is a dump
I live off a couple high ways you know
that LA there's Highways everywhere one
of the exits by my house is just a dump
there's garbage everywhere there's
flipped cones there's crap everywhere
that the sidewalk is busted up blah blah
blah David has been calling our local
representative to get them to take care
of it why would I want to have to call
the federal government to have to come
in and fix that now the local government
hasn't done it yet we're working on it
but I would always want to be governed
more by the people around me in my
community who care and know about the
things that I care and know about and
are that we're all affected by rather
than some supreme power so stop making
it seem like the president is king he
isn't King at least not yet okay Dave
can you give a quick shout out and
support to Majid namazi Quilliam for his
lawsuit against the Southern Poverty Law
Center for labeling him an anti Muslim
extremist of course I think maje is a
great guy
I think the SPLC is off the deep end if
you have to pick who's an extremist
Majin woz or the SPLC it is the SPLC
ignore them ignore them they're garbage
don't give them your money Dave let's
create a new content platform to
circumvent YouTube censorship look it's
interesting the word
there is certain interesting because I
don't know that they're directly
censoring now by D monetizing things at
the level that they're doing it and
again especially where there D
monetizing things before they've even
been tagged by doing that that's not
censorship directly because they're not
saying that I can't put this stuff out
there but we don't truly know what's
going on with this unsubscribe er thing
that I'm talking about with what's
happening with the algorithm are they
just suppressing things I mean we know
people tell me that my videos don't get
put into their feeds so we see certain
videos that I know should be getting
150,000 views that get 20,000 views you
know so is there some level of
censorship is there some level of
political coercion going on there Reid
I'm gonna read I haven't read James
d'amours whole 10 page document yet but
I am gonna read that I have no doubt
that they're fiddling around with
something by the way I did ask in that
phone call with YouTube I did ask them
if they would send a representative here
they said well they'll connect us to the
PR team then there was no follow-up
we'll work on them oh and I asked Jack
from Twitter to do the show and he DM me
and said he would do it I followed up a
couple times haven't heard back yet but
hopefully we can make that happen so
that would be great
okay did you see the Eclipse so I did so
I'm in Los Angeles here and I did go
outside during the Eclipse my mom had
sent me many messages not to stare at
the Eclipse and I saw basically it just
got a little darker here you know wasn't
this wasn't the the ideal state to be to
be seeing it it just got like a little
eerily dark here was it was kind of cool
by the way when I wasn't online and
wasn't tweeting and doing all this
nonsense I get a lot of gardening you
know just as you guys know this is a
home studio that I have here I haven't
even lived here for a year we we moved
in last November so it's you know ten
months or so but I had never owned a
home before this I'm 41 pretty I made it
41 years old I'm I'm a homeowner in
America the America you know it's the
immigrants dream and I did it but just
spending some time at home and feeling
like I own something and I wanted to do
yard work and gardening and painting and
some other stuff like it
he was very validating and again that
goes to why I'm so you know feeling so
much gratitude for those of you that
support me do you bring your dog with
you and did she help you with cardio so
most of the cardio in Mexico I was just
at the the little gym there I did get an
elliptical machine in the house here
because even though I do go to a gym
it's a couple miles away and just
because my schedule has been so nuts I
haven't been able to get there as much
so I just do it in the in the other
bedroom over there and Emma is 13 years
old she's slightly past the point of
doing cardio but she's she's doing great
and looks great for it for a 13 year old
do you generate any relevant revenue
from YouTube red subscribers so there is
a breakdown in our back-end where we can
see you know we made it dismount from
super chat let's say in this amount from
ad Rev and this amount from red so we do
make some from red it's not much but I
don't know how many people actually do
red but if you're on red and you're
watching us we are making something off
you and I do appreciate that have you
explored the non-religious aspects of
Buddhism and meditation I have found
that I'm able to handle the noise in
society and politics today you know I
want so I haven't gotten into meditation
specifically or explored Buddhism too
much but it's funny you say that because
the other day I watched what's love got
to do with it which is the Tina Turner
movie and I love Tina Turner
I put her at the top by the way above
Beyonce love the Tina and I was watching
the movie and in the movie you know she
and it's her life story it's her true
life story her and I Turner had a
horrific relationship and he was
incredibly abusive and drugs and all
that stuff and when she finally tries to
get her life to turn her life around she
gets into Buddhism and chanting and
meditation and all that and it was
making me think the other day that I'd
like to get into it I think basically I
pretty much done a good job of being
able to get out of the noise but again I
did learn this month that I've got to do
a better job of it because because there
is a lot of a lot of noise okay when you
talk to d'amour could you also talk to
someone who took offense at what he
wrote I'm interested in hearing more
what was
offensive about what he wrote best I can
get so far is that talking to groups
somehow puts each individual in that
group most women do don't do as well in
engineering for example therefore this
person as a woman must not be good at
engineering I'll be happy to do that so
let me explore the thing a little bit
more let me read what he said we'll get
him on the show and then I'd be happy to
have someone that has feelings on that a
couple of people are asking about daca
I'm just catching up on the whole thing
so give me give me a couple days on that
one um let's see um I'd love to have you
have Austin Peterson on back now that
he's running for US Senate in Missouri I
really like Austin we had we had a great
conversation here I'm happy I told him
I'd be happy to go to Missouri and
campaign for him look we disagree on
some stuff he's definitely I think a
little more in the libertarian circle
where I think I'm a little more centrist
in some ways he's pro-life on pro-choice
but I think that the basic views of how
he wants government to work and his
defense of liberty and the individual
they supersede whatever little
differences we might have and I don't
know if he if he's gonna win or if he
even has a chance but if I can help him
in any way I'm happy to do that a couple
more people are into the beard okay when
you're gonna have sam harris and ben
shapiro on your show at the same time
they have much to discuss that is not
religion please avoid religion it would
be a massive opportunity cost so I've
thought about it I bounced that idea
around with the two of them I think it
is gonna happen probably relatively soon
but I don't want to speak for either one
of them but yeah I wouldn't want to get
too lost in the specifics of religion I
think actually that it's not really
where either one of them want to spend
most of their time you know been for at
least from what I can tell although he
is religious privately I don't think he
wants to spend a ton of time defending
religion I think he wants to talk about
government and Sam you know look
obviously he's written many of the end
of faith and led her to a Christian
nation and he's you know well-known new
atheist whatever that is but I don't
know that only that he would want to
even sit here and spend so much time
doing the religion thing I think there's
so many other interesting philosophical
things that we can talk about and I'll
see if I can
make that happen okay let's see does
proximity play a role in how seriously
people react to tragedy one was killed
in Charlottesville and it's all over
social media for months yet 13 are
killed in Barcelona and it stayed in
most minds for a few days so it's
interesting so look I'm just catching up
on the Charlottesville thing and I know
that that that one woman was killed
the Barcelona thing which I said was the
one thing that I knew happened but I
just knew something happen because I saw
a hashtag I didn't know 13 people were
killed but you know when I went off the
grid one of the things that I was
thinking before I went off was like I
knew I was gonna miss stuff right like
there's I thought August is basically a
good time because more people are on
vacation the news cycle slows down a
little bit although I guess not in this
particular month but I knew there was no
doubt I was going to miss a terrorist
attack I was gonna miss Trump saying
something crazy I was gonna miss a
series of things and I just had to let
it be I just had to let it be that I
wasn't going to jump back on and get
back into the fray to do it but it's
interesting your question about
proximity because that is one of the
things that I was thinking about a
little bit from being off the grid that
things happen all over the world right
now we are all are on social media and
then we all think it's happening as if
it's happening in our backyard
and I think there's a little bit of a
danger there because it makes your gauge
of how important an issue is or how
relevant to your life it is or any of
that stuff it's sometimes hard to gauge
where that really fits so proximity look
it's a beautiful thing the Internet's a
beautiful thing it's brought so many of
us together my whole life has changed
because of it as I'm sure yours has as
well it's brought down governments it's
created revolutions it's changed things
in science and math and virtually in the
way we communicate we've Sutter and all
that but the proximity thing I do think
is an interesting thing that I'd like to
explore a little bit more all right by
the way guys because I see a lot of
comments classical liberal this is just
one of the many new shirts in the merch
store that I think basically went alive
today the new updated merch store we've
got a new center shirt we've got some
some liberal Defense Force shirts that I
really like some cool Rubin Report stuff
it's Rubin report calm
slash store and by the way that's a way
that if you're if you're not a if you're
not joining us on patreon or you're not
a supporter on PayPal but you want to
just do a one-time thing and make get
something for yourself and help us
continually grow then please do that and
as long as I'm saying that again I do
want to remind you that here we are
doing this on YouTube but it's simply
YouTube because of the D monetization
the algorithms all this nonsense it just
simply is not a place where I feel that
our business can grow any more we will
play by the rules
we don't do clickbait we do the right
titles and tags we don't do misleading
thumbnails we will always continue to
play the game properly here and we'll do
it at the expense by the way of getting
more views because I know there's all
kinds of tricks that we can play and we
were trained in a lot of them and we
don't do them but if you want to help us
grow and expand this show and everything
that we do here and I promise you this
is going to be the biggest year that
we've ever had
it's Rubin report.com slash donate you
can join us monthly or one-time and and
we'll go from there okay let's see um
welcome back Dave glad you've taken off
the grid time and had some physical work
around your house this is our real
regeneration have you become a believer
already by being offline I'm so glad you
asked that question and I wasn't gonna
get into it right now but I'm glad you
asked it and I'm reading all these
things live so you might ask me
something that I'm not prepared to
answer so I do want to say something
about the believer thing so you know
until I started this show on aura two
years ago so earlier before I said the
thing about that I consider this the
third season of this show so you know
originally we when we launched the Rubin
reported we were part of the Young Turks
it was a different show altogether a lot
of things that I was talking about it
was different just the whole thing so I
I kind of put that version of the show
aside then I would view season 1 of the
Rubin report as being when we launched
on aura TV the first episode that I
think most of you have seen was the was
the first time that I had ever met Sam
Harris and we had a great run at aura
and then we decided to leave it had a
lot to do with my original discussion
with your own Brook about rational
self-interest and working for yourself
and all that kind of stuff so I would
consider season one of the Rubin report
was that whole run at aura I would say
season two of the Rubin
report started last June when we decided
to go independent we went on patreon and
this is about you know 14 months ago or
so maybe 15 months now I would consider
that to be season 2 everything we did
from there from going independent to
then buying this house and having a home
studio all of that season 2 I would say
as of today we are now in in season 3
the reason I mentioned all this in terms
of believer is because when we did the
thing on aura and I had Sam on first I
suddenly had a burst of atheists on I
had Michael Shermer on in Peter Bogosian
and obviously Sam and a bunch of others
and my feeling about belief always I
think always in my entire life was that
I just can't believe in something that I
that is improvable but I never really
said that I was an atheist or thought I
not didn't think about it because I'd
spent a lot of time in my life thinking
about it I've mentioned a story a couple
times about how when I was about 20
years old I went to Egypt and I hiked
Mount Sinai which is supposedly where
Moses got the Ten Commandments and I was
ready to have a religious experience and
it just didn't happen it didn't happen
but but in any event I sort of got
pinned into saying I was an atheist
because I had all these people on and by
default if you don't believe in
something you know I peter bagozzi and I
talked a bit about the difference
between atheism and agnosticism I don't
want to get too lost in that right now
but I kind of got pinned into it and one
of the things that I was thinking in
this last month which is why I'm glad
you asked this question and I'll have
some people on to discuss it a little
bit further is I can't look there are
probably things that I believe that I
can't prove so like I'll just give you
an easy one that people use as example
look if you say well do you love your
mother well everyone says yes to that
but how do you prove that how do you
actually prove that is that actually
provable I don't know but what I would
say is I did think there were a few
times again because I was in this place
of real gratitude to you guys and
allowing my brain to just kind of
breathe a little bit more and all that
stuff I was thinking that there's there
are things probably that I believe that
I can't necessarily quite explain or
that I wonder about or whatever and
maybe that's more just the spiritual
side of things I don't think that there
is a man
in the sky who's watching and judging
who I have sex with or what I'm doing
privately or any of that stuff but maybe
the phrase atheist isn't so important
relative to the things that I really
care about isn't that important and that
I possibly believe in some things that I
can't quite explain yet so I'm glad yeah
I don't even know that I fully form that
through yet but I'm glad you asked about
that so thank you um I think it would be
a great idea for you to read 1984 a
chapter at a time periodically maybe get
an or well expert on that that's a great
idea you know I've been thinking about
doing some kind of book club type of
thing with you guys and actually as of I
think it'll kick in and about a week or
so or maybe a just kicked in audible.com
is gonna be one of the sponsors on our
podcast so maybe we could all do
audiobooks together and then I can have
either the authors on or people that are
experts in it or things like that
alright gentle about go over to patreon
what's your opinion on price gouging
during natural disasters should the
government intervene in situations like
hurricane Harvey where some people are
charging $100 for water or $10 for gas
or should the free market be left to
correct the price increase on its own so
it's a great it's a great question
because it's that constant blend between
government and free markets yet you have
a situation like this where there's
truly a matter of life or death I don't
want to get too much into the specifics
of this hurricane because I don't know
that much yet should the government step
in I think in a case of a natural
disaster that if there are places
selling bottles of water for $100 that I
think you can make a very strong
sensible argument that there has to be
some regulation of that it's an extreme
case where something where things are so
out of the ordinary that I don't know
that the free market can can solve that
properly yes we would love and it would
be more ideal if a hurricane hits if
every store that is in the town says
we're gonna sell water for a dollar or
we're gonna give it away we're gonna
give it away and then maybe the
government will come in and give us some
extra funding effort I think I do know
unfortunately I don't think you can stop
people I mean should we be fining people
or arresting people for price gouging
it's a slippery slope it's a good
argument and a good discussion to have
and I'm happy to have it more if you are
starting a new season it's getting
pretty close for time for a Sam Harris
episode three Revenge of the mindful I
will absolutely talk to Sam about that
this is a request for a panel featuring
Jordan Peterson and Jonathan hate I
think we're going to try to make
something along those lines work just
jump up to super chat a couple times
okay well you know what let me address
something else so I guess a few of you
were saying that I've that I've said I'm
an atheist in conversations with guests
so that's what I'm saying is that I had
never said it before I'm 99% sure and
anyone who's welcome to correct me on
this that I had never said it publicly
until my interview with Peter Bogosian
the first one which I think was in if
I'm not mistaken it was in October of
October or November 99% sure it was
November of 2015 I think that was the
first time I had ever said it I was
always happy to have the conversations
with atheists and all that stuff I what
I'm saying now is I'm not making any
major change other than I'm just saying
do I think that there's possibly some
things that I believe in that I can't
quite explain that I just can't quite
explain I'm not even sure what they are
I think that's possible and I don't
think that I don't think that's um not
mark on my intellect or anything like
that I think a lot of us have these sort
of in these idiosyncratic little things
popping around in our head that don't
all fully line up all the time and I'll
come back and talk about this more and
get the right people on to talk about it
more it's just something that's been
just something it's been bouncing around
okay here well you know we're just gonna
do a couple more here cuz I got Phil
DeFranco coming in I've got to catch up
on a zillion things I'm glad so many
people like the beard I'm glad to see it
okay which idea do you think is more
powerful history repeats itself or learn
from history to not make the same
mistakes I think this is the unstoppable
force versus the movable object idea it
absolutely is that idea I don't know
that there's even much of a difference
between those two things I think the
history repeats itself thing I love that
phrase it's simple everyone can
understand what it means and it shows
you that you know everyone see now we
live in the worst time ever
or now we live in the most enlightened
time ever oh never and it's like we
still have to be weary of the things
that consistently repeat our repeat in
civilizations people that get too much
power the the desire for authoritarians
to control how you act and how you think
all of those things so history does
repeat itself and hopefully that's why
education is so important because you
want people to understand this is what
happened in the past and it could happen
again
don't think that it can't do you suppose
you can do another youtuber we maybe get
Ethan from h3h3
I can see you two gelling rather well
together huge inspiration by the way we
have reached out to him a couple times
before and it hasn't happened but we're
absolutely gonna do another YouTube week
soon we're gonna do another fan show
soon which I can't wait to do
have you considered having Peter Schiff
or Tom woods both have connections to
Ron Paul those names are definitely on
our on our master list we're trying to
get Ron Paul I think we are learn
liberty folks have been trying to get
them so we'll see about that during the
time off the grid did you mentally
revisit any old interviews do you have
any new thoughts on old conversations I
think I don't know that I revisited any
so specifically like oh I should have
said this or that what I really did
think about though was the sort of
trajectory of what we're doing with the
show and how I can how I can tighten it
how I can get better how I can learn
more how we can expand it more so for
example what I referred to as season 1
before that first season that launched
with Sam on aura that's really when the
phrase regressive left was starting to
gain traction had a lot to do with what
we were doing on the show and a lot of
my guests were form I would say were
former leftist or they were people of
the left who were being abandoned by the
left
people like Faisal saitama tar and Sarah
hater and Sam and ayaan and all these
people liberals who were being abandoned
we spent a lot of time really talking
about the regressive left and that whole
thing I think we named a problem you
know it's the irony of the label thing
everyone doesn't want to use labels but
sometimes there's this the amorphous
idea that we were all having about how
hysterical the Left became the phrase
regressive left I think helped us
coalesce around that and understand what
we were dealing with I don't use the
phrase really anymore very rarely
because I'm trying to get away from
labels as much as I can but sometimes
sometimes you do need them and nobody's
perfect by the way but anyway the second
the this last year of the show I think
we had a really great mix of people all
over the map although my my critics will
say he puts these all right people on I
don't I mean who did I have that was
alright the the people that I've had I
say that we are the furthest right I had
Mike CERN image on before he was anybody
we were trying to find anyone that would
publicly support Trump and and he was
the one guy we could find
obviously I've had Milo on a couple of
times beyond that anyone that's all try
I've had Milo on twice alright I mean I
guess maybe if you consider Lauren
southern alright but short of that most
someone did a breakdown on Facebook
right before I left most of the guests
that we've had have been liberals
they've act they're liberals now they're
not regressives or they may not be
leftist but they're liberal then we've
obviously had a lot of conservatives on
we've obviously a deliberate a lot of
libertarians on my point being that over
the next year I want to not only keep
branching out in all of those directions
but I maybe want to do a little more on
science I mean I think there's all kinds
of AI a lot of other interesting things
that we can do and also my I think what
my real goal for this year will be is
that for the first year we were
identifying a problem for the second
year I think we sort of talked about
that problem with a whole host of
different people and I think for what
I'm gonna try to do this year is find
some real solutions to this stuff I
think one of the biggest problems right
now is that everybody whether you're a
Trump person earned oh yeah and you're a
resistance person whatever the hell you
are I think everyone feels like the
whole thing is spinning out of control
and no one is trying to stop the this
monster no one's trying to stop the
craziness everyone's just kind of
joining the craziness and what I'm
really gonna try to do with this show
going forward is is get some concrete
answers I'm gonna continue to tell you
what I think and and hopefully hopefully
when you get in a conversation and
people are at each other's throats
you'll be like you know what you should
watch this video right here because that
will encapsulate what I think about this
or it's the best explanation of how do
we get out of this malaise or any of
that stuff okay just a couple more
minutes here welcome back Dave the
Internet feels lonely without you it's
good it's
to be back so far although we're doing
this very one-way but it's nice to be
back a couple more things on the beard
let's see is ball life I think you're
referring to basketball I'm gonna
finally start playing in a weekly game
again probably in about two weeks now my
knee is my knees in better shape and I'm
looking forward to that let's see
alright last couple stuff here I guess
you need to have more money more
conversations about religions
philosophies and ideologies then are you
making any distinction between the three
I'll be happy to dive into that in
another time YouTube Twitter and
Facebook are becoming sensor Asst and
less profitable because of this would
you consider moving to another site or
starting your own site with other voices
there's a lot of discussion being
happening happening right now about this
trust me there's a ton and I'm sure I'm
not privy to all of them I have no doubt
that I'm not but there's a lot of
discussion look I at the end of the day
right now I am sitting in my transformed
garage a great studio that we've built
and this is by the way there's another
thing that we that I said to the to the
YouTube people I said look guys I
mentioned a little bit earlier but that
I give you a television quality show
this thing could be on HBO tomorrow now
we do this show for a budget I think
probably what we do the budget that we
do this show for for a year is probably
probably less than the budget that it
takes to do one night of Anderson Cooper
or whatever is on CNN on any given night
the amount of staff and all the stuff
that they have we we have built
something everything that we have here
if you're a member on patreon and you
get some of the behind the scenes videos
if you see what our lighting grid looks
like if you see the cameras that we have
everything that we've built here are
control of all of that stuff we've built
industry standard stuff here as I said
we just invested in new lights all of
this stuff and at some point if YouTube
doesn't allow us to make money off of it
off of the product that obviously
thousands and thousands if not millions
of people really appreciate and enjoy
then at the end of the day I'll put this
out whatever if this camera works and
that wire works and the Wi-Fi works and
this can get out to where we get well if
you're watching on YouTube or
listening to the podcast or your on vid
me your minds or gab or wherever the
hell you are right I think it's great so
we just have to figure out how to do
some of that stuff if you're interested
in joining us it's Rubin report comm
station
donate and let me just let me just knock
out knock out one more love your work
thanks for bringing real ass news to
YouTube the true mainstream media are
you planning on interviewing Ethan Klein
from a THC alright we'll try to make it
happen alright so I think I think we
should probably wrap it up there because
I have so much to catch up on I mean I
literally didn't check emails I had an
out-of-office on my work but not on my
personal even turning back on my phone I
had a gajillion text I by the way I
could figure out which friends of mine
watch my show or not because I had
people texting me not realizing that I
wasn't off the grid but anyway just to
to wrap all this stuff up we're gonna do
James tomorrow we're trying to settle on
when we're gonna do that I think it'll
be a live stream
we've got Blair white we're going to a
live stream on that it might be this
Friday but we're trying to maybe move
her to Tuesday just because a couple
logistical things as I said Phil
DeFranco taping it later today that'll
be up tomorrow but more more than
anything else I I hope you can you can
see it and hear it in me I just I just
genuinely I thank you guys I wish I
could figure out the right way to thank
all of you who support us to do this you
gave me an incredible opportunity this
month that if you care about the ideas
that we're doing here trust me I am
rejuvenated and reinvigorated to
strengthen these ideas and to keep
figuring out new ways to get this stuff
out there and continue to do good work
so I hope that I was missed a little bit
but I hope also that you'll take a
little time and occasionally get off
this stuff and I'll accept it if you
can't retweet everything that I do or
post every video that I do on Facebook
but I'm gonna try in general to do maybe
do many ones every weekend now just
getting off the grid because I do think
everyone's just slammed with this
nonsense let's figure out together how
to how to fight this monster of of fake
news of anger of hostility of all of
those things if anything hit me over the
last month just talking to people all
the time you know I mean just talking
and listening to people and all that
stuff that's what's important and that's
what I'm going to keep doing
so I am back in business baby I think
the beards gonna stay did anyone not
like it
were there any comments that they did
not like the beer to we'll review but
either way I kind of I kind of dig it
this is this is no shaving for exact is
it's exactly one month today probably
anyway so thank you guys again it's
Rueben report coms last store if you
want to check out some of the new merch
we've got over there if you want to
support its rubin report comm / donate i
thank you i got a big day ahead of me
because i got i got roughly four
bajillion things to do and i'm gonna try
not to be on my computer all day long
and and we will continue this so thank
you i may the force be with you
[Music]